Hello world,
it's to Raj and don't go anywhere.
This is going to be one of the most
important videos you've ever seen in your
life.
So sit down and enjoy the ride.
What I'm going to do in this video is
I'm going to build a voting APP, okay?
And let me demo it first. Okay.
This is my hello world voting APP.
It's got three candidates and
I'm going to vote for one.
I'm going to pick one Rama and then
click vote and the vote shows up. Okay?
There are three candidates in this app.
I voted and then the vote shows up and
anybody who uses this app can vote and
then that vote is going to show up in
the web app. So you might be thinking,
wait a second, it's so easy.
Why are you demoing this?
Because the difference between this
voting app and a normal voting app is that
this voting APP is unhackable.
That means that no one can
modify the votes, the w, okay,
so it is hackable,
but it's hackable in that you wouldn't
have to have access to the 500 fastest
supercomputers in the world combined.
That's how much computing power you
would have to have in order to hack this.
So it's basically unhackable unless
you have that much computing power,
which no one does. And this is
called a decentralized application.
Now you are probably used to building a
centralized application. So am I right?
That's what we do. We all have a web
development, all of mobile development,
all of it is centered around
building centralized software.
And we're going to talk
about what centralized and
decentralized are in a second.
But that's the,
that's the voting app we're going to do.
That's the demo we're
going to build today.
I'm going to go through setting up the
environment and all the tools you need to
build it and then we'll
build it ourselves.
But first let's talk a little bit
about the worldwide web. Okay.
So the web started off decentralized.
What does that mean?
If you are around in the early nineties
and I was a little baby, but you know,
I was still there. Uh, then if
you want it to make a website,
you would just buy a server, right?
You buy a server that has a computer,
you put it in your room and then you
would put your webpage or your blog,
they weren't even called blogs
back then, but you're, you know,
whenever you want it on your server
or on your computer and then you,
you owned that server because no one
was offering to host your data for you.
What that meant was the web consisted of
a series of nodes that were all linked
together,
a very neutral playing
field where everybody owned
their data or the data that
they contributed to the worldwide web.
That's how the web started off.
But what happened was
during the.com bubble,
entrepreneurs realized that if you
want it to provide value on top of this
neutral playing field, then you
would create some service, right?
You create some service and that service
would collect data and monetize it.
And this per proved, extremely,
extremely useful, right?
We started hosting our data on Geo cities.
If you remember,
shout out to Geo cities or any of the
old, you know, web hosting services.
We started using,
you know,
a whole host of services that were
centralized and what this meant was you
didn't have to buy your own server.
You could just use these services
and have a very thin client.
But what's happened is these services
have become so massive that the web is now
a scent. A set is, it's, it's
basically a handful of huge nodes.
It's become centralized around a handful
of of huge notes and these notes are
Amazon, Google, Facebook, snapchat,
Instagram.
All data is routed through
these all data requests,
all queries data is routed through
the central nodes and this is bad,
really bad.
And here's why we of course,
the services provided great value to our
lives. We use them every day, right? We,
I use Google and all the services
every day, they make our lives easier,
but it's bad for four reasons. The first
reason is that it shrinking our economy.
What I mean by that is that in a good
economy we monetize more and more,
but in a bad economy we
monetize less and less.
And that's what's happening because data
is the natural resource of our time.
And because data is so centralized,
that means the ownership
of data is so centralized,
there are less opportunities for people
to generate value to generate capital
because all the data is being collected,
right? Data is how you make money, right?
As a society,
we are starting to value more and more
data and less and less labor. Right?
Before we valued labor.
Now not so much.
It's all about the data and as this uh,
economic trend progresses,
it's going to only, the value of data
is only going to increase over time.
And because that data
is so siloed right now,
it's hard for normal people
to make money off of it.
You would have to be a part of one
of these big corporations to do so.
And that's not the future that
we want. Right? Uh, so that's,
that's a problem.
The other problem is that,
that this is just too much concentrated
power, right? Knowledge is power, right?
And knowledge is data, information is
power. Information is data. And it's,
it's just too much of an overhead God
view of what everybody is doing for any of
these companies to have Uber.
For example,
I had a friend who will remain
nameless who worked at Uber,
who showed me God mode.
And if you don't know God mode is what
they are able to view all Uber rides that
are happening obviously at the same time.
So they can, they can basically predict,
you know, who's having a one
night stand or who is, you know,
anything really personal details
they can glean from this.
And that's just one of many,
many,
many examples and that that is
just too much power for any,
any one entity to have.
And that's just not good because it
doesn't matter what our intentions were.
This is a problem and we have no say
in how our data is used, right? Once,
once we exchange our data control of
our data for access to a free service.
And what this means is they
can do anything with our data.
They can sell it to advertisers,
they can use it to manipulate us,
they can learn our personal details,
they can sell it to the u s
government or any governments really.
And we just have no say in
how this goes in the end.
The last point is that we should
be paid for our data. We need to,
we are generating this valuable resource,
this natural resource,
and we should be paid for it.
So a great book on this is called
who owns the future by Jerome Linear.
The dude looks really wild. He's got
these long dreadlocks and he, you know,
big Dude in Berkeley and he plays all
these instruments. He's a really cool guy,
but I mean, no one can talk about this
in the way that your own linear can.
He's one of the pioneers of the Internet.
He now works at Microsoft
research as a virtual reality, uh,
researcher and a, yeah, so that's
a great book. And also, I mean,
I wrote the book on
decentralized applications.
I don't really talk about it that much
because the code is deprecated at this
point. But, um, yeah, if you want to see a
great book on decentralized applications,
then check out my book. It's an O'Reilly
book as well, but the code is deprecated,
but the idea is remain. I just don't
have time to keep maintain that code.
I'm making videos like a madman.
Anyway, back to this. So let's,
let's talk about this decentralized
versus centralized versus distributed.
What is the difference?
So a centralized application is what
we're used to Google, Facebook, Amazon.
What happens with the
centralized application is we
create a server and then we
have a bunch of clients
connect to that server.
So everybody connects to these,
this central point of authority
that defines the rules
of how the network works.
An example is Facebook, right? We,
whenever we go to facebook.com we're,
our browsers are acting as clients that
in our browsers are requesting data from
Facebook and posting data to Facebook.
It's a central server and
that's how pretty much all
of the web works right now.
It's easy. It was just easy to
do. That's why we did it. And,
but it's difficult to scale and it
has a single point of failure, right?
If someone takes down that data center,
all of our data is lost.
So that's centralized.
Let me talk about distributed next,
which is this right here,
this image right here.
So a distributed system is one worse
computation is spread out across the
network. So, um,
actually all of the services
that we use are distributed.
So a service can be both centralized.
That means there is a central point
of authority and distributed as in the
computation is spread across multiple
nodes. Because if you think about it,
Facebook doesn't just
have one giant server.
They have several data centers that are
scattered across the web and data is
routed through the servers
depending on where you are. And uh,
so the services are both
centralized and they're distributed.
And so this having a distributed
architecture speeds of computing,
and it's just data latency, it
increases bandwidth. There's a,
there's a bunch of pros to having
a distributed architecture.
It's a little harder,
but the pros are worth it.
And that's why these big
companies do that. Now,
the last one I'm going to talk
about are decentralized systems,
like the middle picture right here.
So for a decentralized system
in a decentralized system, uh,
you can take away one of those nodes
and the network will still run.
That means that no note is
telling any other node what to do.
There is no central point of authority.
All nodes are equal and the network
in terms of their authority. Uh,
so bitcoin is a,
is an example of an,
of a system of a network that is both
distributed because it's a timestamp to
public ledger. It's a, it's a database
where everybody owns a copy of the data,
right?
They resides on multiple computers.
So it's distributed and it's decentralized
because if one node goes down,
the network is still able to operate,
right? You could take down, you know,
20 bitcoin miners, but bitcoin would
still run. It's a, it's, it's a,
it's a more resilient way of building
software. It's faster software.
The demand and failures
are better handled.
So examples of decentralized software are
all of these crypto currencies that we
look at. Bitcoin, ethereum lite coin,
these are all decentralized systems.
And when it comes to
decentralized applications, um,
there's really only one that satisfies
my criteria, at least right now.
And that's called Steemit.
And I'll talk about that in a second.
But a steam at is one,
what does a profitable
decentralized application look like?
So if we look at the web 2.0 stack, okay,
let's look at the the web 2.0 stack.
So anytime you want to build software
and any kind of web APP or mobile app,
you are using these tools right there.
There are certain parts of a website or
an APP that you need to use tools for,
right? So four payments, you're going
to use credit cards and paypal, stripe,
some kind of API for
monetization. You know, you'll,
you'll develop some
strategy like selling ads,
pay wall and your content selling some
good, uh, some goods, external data.
You use a third party Api from
some service, right? Like, um,
clarify or any of these
APIs for file storage,
you use Amazon s three or Google
cloud or you know, what have you.
And lastly for computation, you use
Amazon [inaudible] or Heroku or you know,
there's a lot of services
out there because web 2.0
has been around for so long,
but now we are moving into web 3.0 and
that means that because of the invention
of a certain set of technologies in
order a bit torrent which maximize
bandwidth,
bitcoin,
which allowed for decentralized consensus
amongst a set of nodes in a system for
the first time, uh, several
of these technologies,
we are now able to make
decentralized apps.
So the web is kind of like a pendulum
and it started off as centralized and it
start off as decentralized.
It moved to centralized and now
it's moving back to decentralized.
And that is the mission of the many of
many developers right now it's to breed,
decentralize the web. And so there are
tools out there that will let us do that.
A theory on Bitcoin, all these
cryptocurrencies are for payments.
That token model for monetization.
Now this is a really interesting bit
and I'll talk about the token model in a
second.
Oracle's for external data.
Oracle's our third party data sources
that you don't have to trust a human for,
like you have to trust, um, stripe or
any of these APIs to provide valid data.
But an oracle is essentially a smart
contract that has some data that you can
trust,
but it's run by machines for file storage.
You would use a network like
the interplanetary file system,
which I'll talk about, which is
essentially a big distributed hash table.
And lastly, for a computation you would
use etherium for example, which is a,
which is a decentralized virtual machine.
It's kind of like a decentralized
Heroku that you could push code to,
but it doesn't leave on one central
server. It's, it's, it's decentralized.
And so I put rep, you know,
ready for these bottom tube
and these are in progress.
But really like if you think about
it, you can use all of these. It's,
it's just not going to be at
the, um, these tools aren't
as evolved as, you know,
the web 2.0 tools, but you can use
all of them for sure. So what does,
what does it look like?
Well,
there are four features that make up a
profitable decentralized application.
The first feature is that
it's open source. So you might
be asking, wait a second,
if I open source my code,
couldn't someone just steal it then?
And now if you're using a
traditional business model, yes.
If a competitor can see your code,
a lot of the times that he's
your competitive advantage,
they could then just use that code and
then fork it and then profit off of your
coat. But in a decentralized application,
if you're using a token business model,
an APP coin model, then they could
not take away from your network,
right? Because it depends on the
community of users. It depends on, um,
it depends on the trust of your
users and that you're, you're,
you're users are profiting
from your model as well.
So people want to join the
network that has the most trust,
that's built the most trust over time.
Trust is a moving concept.
It's not just established once.
You have to continually
prove and reprove that trust.
And so people want to go with the
longest, a chain of trust, so to speak.
The second feature is the use
of cryptocurrency. So this is a,
this is an image of, of uh, some
random, uh, companies, uh, timeline for,
for ICO or initial coin
offering. But basically, um,
the use of cryptocurrency is this.
So you know,
their traditional models for
monetization, right? The transaction fees,
advertising revenues, but the
cryptocurrency way is to do this. Okay?
So you would allocate some scarce resource
in your network using a scarce token,
right? That's scarce resource could
be storage space, it could be images,
it could be videos,
some scarce resources and scarce data.
That's people are contributing
to the network that,
and you monetize that with an app coin,
some kind of token.
And what happens is users need this
app co op coin to access the scarce
resource. And because of
that, you're creating a supply
and a demand, right? You're,
you're drinking, posing this artificial
scarcity. And what that does is owners,
all the scarce resource
get paid in APP coins.
So they get paid for their tweets and
their images and the whatever data that
they contribute. And what this does is
it makes the value of the APP coin arise,
right? So this app coin is
kind of like a hybrid asset.
It's both a stock but
it's also a currency.
And so it's both. It's not
right. So you can make,
you can own it and you can just keep it
as investment or you can use it and you
or you could just use, do both, keep
it, keep a part of it as an investment.
And the other part has, has use
of that, of that, of that APP.
So that's one way in bitcoin does as well.
File coin does as well,
like in the fall coin network,
miners of the scarce resorts storage space
get paid in file coin and then people
who want to store their data on the file
coin network pay have to pay file coin
to access it.
And so there is this market that's been
created and this can apply to any kind
of decentralized application and a
scarce resource could be anything, right?
So steam, it is a great example of
a decentralized application, right?
Because, uh, there is
because there is a digital point system
and people are getting paid for their
scarce resource, which, which are
their posts. As you can see here,
they're the most valuable posts
are the most paid posts and uh,
it's open source.
It uses cryptocurrency under the hood,
but it's got a dollar rapper here,
but anyone can pay and cryptocurrency.
So Steven is a great example of a,
of a working decentralized application.
The third feature is
decentralized consensus.
So what I mean by that is the ability for
a network to all agree upon everything
that's happening in the APP.
And only until very recently,
this was not possible.
Bitcoin proved that we could reach
decentralized consensus using the proof of
work algorithm.
51% of the nodes in the bitcoin network
have to approve a transaction before
it's made valid and added to the
chain of blocks, the block chain.
And not just an,
as they vote on the
validity of a transaction,
they also have to offer a proof
of their computational work.
And so what this means
is they have to have,
you have to have more computing power
than 51% of the bitcoin network in order
to fake a transaction.
And that's where the 500
fastest supercomputers phrase
I talked about comes from.
And so that's,
that was one very popular way of
reaching decentralized consensus.
And so another thing is the
blockchain alone isn't enough.
It's not just like you just
take an application, sprinkle
some blockchain on it,
and you're good. No, blockchain is a,
is a big part of it is a data
structure that you would use,
but it's only a part of the stack.
So for big files,
you're not going to store big files
on a blockchain, right? For big files,
you're going to store that on some
kind of distributed hash table.
And one that I really like is called IPFS,
which I'll talk about for feature for,
but right, so you use a distributed hash
table to store the data and then you,
you'd use a blockchain
for APP level constructs.
These are timestamped constructs,
like usernames and status
updates and high scores.
Anything that you need the
network to agree on, agree upon.
And so the reason you use a DHT and a
blockchain is because the blockchain
solves the major security
issue of the HTS,
which is not forcing nodes to trust
each other on the validity of the data.
So the DHT is more of like a dumb data
store that no one controls and the block
chain helps to DHT reach
consensus on the data,
which lets you create
applications on top of it. Lastly,
there's the idea of smart contracts,
which are crypto economically
secured bits of code, right?
So in a normal piece of code. Now here's
an example. In a normal piece of code,
you would upload it to some
central computation engine
like Heroku and then you
would trust Heroku to compile
that code and keep that code,
uh,
an unmodified just like you pushed.
But in a smart contract, you don't
have to trust any central source.
You push it directly to a blockchain.
Ideally the ethereum blockchain,
because they have a touring
complete block chain,
which allows for loops and all sorts
of application level constructs.
But you would push some code
to the ethereum blockchain
and then it would run on
that blockchain.
And so everybody,
every miner has a piece of that code
and it's Crypto, economically secured.
So it's that.
What that means is it is a pre agreed
upon snippet of code that wants deployed
is unchangeable. It is immutable.
Okay, so that's a smart contract.
And lastly, for a profitable
decentralized application,
there is no central point of failure.
That means that you just could not take
this application down if you want it to.
So, right. So all of these big countries
that try to block access like China to
applications like Facebook,
they could not do that for,
for a decentralized
application. Why? Well,
one way is again,
to use IPFS as your data store.
So IPFS and I, I won the creator
of, this was my roommate when,
when he was writing the paper,
and there's a lot, there's a lot.
I could do an entire video series on IPFS.
There's a lot here,
but basically it is a replay.
It is meant to be a replacement for http,
which isn't the normal way in which we
access websites on the Internet right now.
So for IPFS there are certain technologies
and you can see them here that that
makeup it's stack.
But the idea for IPFS is that
instead of Ip addressing our web,
instead of Ip addressing our content,
meaning we location address where some
data is let's content address it and
access it that way. So instead of going
to a website by using its Ip address,
we would use its content address, kind
of like get right, like get has those,
these hashes that represent data.
So IPFS is essentially
like a giant get tree,
a miracle Dag as,
as they call it in IPFS.
We're all data is linked together and
there's resiliency happening in the
network as well.
Bits and shards of data or
replicated across multiple nodes.
So you couldn't just take down some
content address because there are multiple
copies of it. They're constantly being
replicated inside of the network. Uh,
so you could take down a website
by just ddosing it, right?
But you could not DDoSs and IPFS
node because the data is replicated.
It's not location addressed,
it's content addressed.
And there's a lot of reasons for
creating IPFS that I could go into.
But basically it helps us create a
permanent web where links never die.
So it's more resilient web
then http. Okay. So, and it's,
it's decentralized. So in, in general,
these technologies are all away for us
to build more autonomous software that is
software that is independent
of its creators. It's, it's,
it's almost like where,
you know,
with AI and with blockchain and all of
these very interesting new technologies,
we are creating ways of removing
the human from the loop.
Because with humans there is always
some kind of trust involved, right?
Whether it's a taxi and you know,
having to trust the taxi driver to give
you a fair price or using some kind of
meter,
right?
So you offload that trust onto the
machine and so you don't have to trust a
human and it just makes the whole process,
the whole system better.
So with artificial intelligence
and with blockchain,
it's our way of making
more autonomous software.
It's almost like entities that live and
exist independently on the Internet.
And this was very exciting.
So I have this image right here.
So just we'll get the one on the box on
the left. Let me just talk about that.
So the,
the,
the old way of creating organizations
companies was that humans at the edges and
humans at the center, just humans. And
those are boring old organizations.
The next step is to have automation
at the edges and humans at the center.
So the assembly line is a great example.
Robots are doing all the grunt work,
but humans are overhead watching it
now where we're heading towards our
distributed autonomous
organizations, which is what
adapt is another word for it.
And that means automation is at the
center, the trust is in the blockchain.
It's in these distributed,
decentralized technologies
and humans are at the edges.
So the community kind of
supports this autonomous network.
So like a decentralized Uber, the drivers
would be at the edges of the network,
but they would have more of a say in
how the network operates than in a model
like Uber, which is centralized.
And lastly, you would have
automation at the edge.
It's an automation at the center and
that is just the holy grail, right?
Just pure Ai. So in the end, these
technologies are all really related.
Lastly, before we, before
I go into the code,
this blockchain and the ICO model
is just a way for us to more closely
approximate the,
uh,
the value generation and
capital generation, right?
That's what we're trying to do because
a lot of times capital generation and
value generation are just not aligned.
What that,
what I mean is people do things that
are not providing a lot of value,
but they get paid a lot of money like
football players or Kim Kardashians or
right.
All these people who are making millions
of dollars but not really providing
real value to society.
Whereas the social impact causes that
are fighting climate change and trying to
solve cancer, they have to raise
money. They're considered nonprofits.
But with the blockchain model,
we can more closely
approximates this so we can,
we can give these people more money. They
can earn as much money as they deserve.
And so it's a really exciting time if
you want to monetize more social impact
causes like volunteering
or scientific research,
like the people who were working on
a theory, them are extremely wealthy.
And some of the original
scientists that worked on it,
independent scientists who
were doing research that was
worthy of turning awards,
they were, they were, they were
incentivized with the ether coin,
which is skyrocketed in value,
right?
So it's a way to more closely,
you know,
give value or capital to the people at
generating real value for the world.
Let's get into our voting APP.
So this is the first step is for
us to set up our environment.
So what we're gonna do
is we're going through,
just use etherium and I know
I talked about IPFS. That's,
that's where maybe a later
tutorial right now, just a very,
very simple application.
We don't really need a distributed hash
table for this because it's so simple.
It's essentially just a smart contract
that we deployed to a blockchain.
And then we have a thin client that
can access that smart contract on the
blockchain,
which is just html and Java script.
So this is what it looks like,
right?
So we have the etherium blockchain,
which is a blockchain like bitcoin,
except it's a Turing complete.
So that means we can,
there is a scripting language associated
with this that we can deploy to not
just transactions but code.
We can have code run on the blockchain
and then we can access that code just
like we would have server. And so this
is called the etherium virtual machine.
And then we would have, we have some thin
client, which is called web three js,
which we're going to access this from.
And we can do all of this from a
web browser. So that's, that's,
that's what it's gonna look like. So
let's go ahead and set up our environment.
Okay. So the first step
is for us to download, um,
the theory, I'm test RPC. Well this is a,
this is an in memory blockchain and
it's great for testing out a blockchain,
having to download the actual blockchain.
Okay.
So we're going to go ahead and install
that by running npm install ethereum js
test RPC and web three in row.
Now remember web three is our thin client
that lets us access the blockchain,
but basically test RPC is gonna let us
create 10 test accounts that we can play
with automatically.
And these accounts are going to be,
are going to come preloaded with a
hundred ethers. These are fake ethers.
It's you also call them gas in etherium
like this is how the network runs,
like you make transactions
and these transactions or
how you deploy contracts to
the blockchain, right? And so because
it's happening on a test network,
we don't have to pay anything
at all, right? It's all free.
But this is on the test network. So it's
going to take a, it's going to, you know,
download all this stuff and when it's
done we're going to go to step two,
which is creating a voting smart contract.
Okay, now it's done. All right, so,
so that was our first step.
And so now we're going to create
our voting smart contract.
We're going to use [inaudible] language,
which is called solidity for
programmings are smart contract.
We're going to deploy that contract to
the ethereum blockchain and it's going to
consist of two functions.
One is going to return the total votes
a candidate has received and the other
two increment the vote
count of four candidate.
And these deployed
contracts are immutable.
If we have any changes we want to make,
we would just deploy a new contract unlike
in irregular web app where you could
just modify the existing code. You
can't do that. These are, these are,
these are immutable pieces of code.
So we would just upload a new contract if
we wanted to make any changes, uh, and,
and we can link them back to each other.
I'll get if we want it to.
But to do this, we're going to
first install the solidity compiler,
which is also an Mpm,
a node package.
So we can run NPM install Sol,
see the solidity compiler.
And when we're done with that, we'll
go ahead and code this thing, right?
So let's write some solidity here,
shall we?
So we're going to start off by
saying, uh, we're going to specify,
we're going to start up by specifying
the version of the compiler that we want
to use.
Whole 0.41.
Now we're going to create our contracts.
So we could think of
this as kind of like a,
a class in whatever your favorite
object oriented language is. Okay?
So,
so this is our voting contract.
Our first bit is to create a mapping fuel,
which is the equivalent of creating
an associative array or hash.
And what this is going to do
is we're going to say, uh,
we're going to say you can't Tate.
And this is a public, this is the
number of votes we've received.
It's a key of the map in the key of the
mapping is the candidate name is Stuart
has the type bytes,
32 in the value is an unsigned
integer to store the vote count.
Okay? So that is our, uh,
number of votes received that
we're going to store here now.
So literally,
so solidity doesn't let us pass in an
array of strings in the constructor yet.
So we're going to use an
array of bytes, 32 bytes, 32,
okay.
Uh, to store the list of
candidates, right? And we
want to have three candidates.
So I'm going to say candidate list.
Then we're going to create our
constructure, our con, our constructor,
which is going to be called once
when we deploy the contract, right?
So this is our voting constructor, right?
For our class it's going to be uptight,
block 32, and the parameter is
going to be the candidate names.
And inside of the constructor we can set
our variable candidate list candidate
list to the parameter candidate names,
which is how we initialize it.
Okay? So then when we deploy the contract,
when a pass an array of candidates,
we will be contesting in the, in the
election. And so once we have that,
we can return,
it will create a function that's going
to return the total votes for the
candidate that candidate has
received so far. And the, again,
the parameter is going to be the candidate
and then it's going to return the
total votes as a,
uh,
integer k as an integer.
And so yes,
we can go ahead and return it.
Votes received candidates.
Now we're going to, we're
going to create, wait, so,
so now we have two more functions.
So the next function is going
to be to vote for the candidate,
right? So this is the function
that increments the vote
count for the specified
candidate. And it's equivalent to casting
about, so for voting for a candidate,
so voting for candidate,
that's going to be bytes
32 for a given candidate,
we want to say if it's a valid candidate.
So if the candidate is valid and
we'll write that, that function last.
So if this candidate is valid,
votes received four
candidate plus equals one.
So if, if, if it is a valid candidate,
then and only then do we
increment the vote count. If
not, then we, then we don't.
So this last function is going to help
us decide if a candidate is valid or not.
So we'll say bytes 32
candidate returns.
Bull.
Okay. So we're going to say, okay,
we're going to create a loop.
And now here is the completeness coming
out, right? Cause because we can do loops.
We couldn't do loops in a Bitcoin
scripting language as Toshi did this for
security reasons. But, um,
overall we need this if we're going
to be able to build robust, capable,
uh,
applications on top of it.
So we're going to say go through the
list of candidates and if the given
candidate is inside of
the list of candidates,
then and only then do
we know that it is a,
in fact a valid candidate because we pass
in a candidate name from our thin web
client. Okay. So that's it for our, uh,
code. Let me return false at the end.
Return. False. Okay. That's it for,
that's it for our solidity code.
And then for our client,
our client is going to be simple html,
right?
So we have some table that's going to
show this, the three candidates, Roma,
nick and Jose. And then
we have um, uh, this,
this on click code. That's going to
say once you type in a name like Rama,
and then you hit boat, it's going to
execute this function, vote for candidate.
And then it's going to update that.
So in the javascript section,
we can see what this code looks like.
Okay.
Right here. But what happens is, uh,
we say we create a new web three object.
We then retrieve that that contract
that we've deployed to the blockchain.
And then we vote for the candidate or we,
we retrieve the content that we deployed
to the blockchain. And then we use that.
We then we then update the,
we then send the vote from the string,
the string vote that we did in the web
app to the blockchain to update the
candidate.
And then we can retrieve it from the
blockchain and then display it in the html
web app. So, uh,
so then we can say, okay, so
after riding our smart contract,
we're going to use web three js to
deploy our APP and interact with it.
So our first step,
Lee makes us bigger,
is to open up the node console. And then
we're going to say, okay, so web three,
we're going to initialize our web three
object require web three. Oh Shit.
Okay,
hold on.
Web three equals require web three.
Okay. And so that, okay,
so we did that. And so now we're going
to say web three equals new web three
and we'll create a,
an instance,
a local host instance for this to let
us access the ethereum blockchain,
the test chain from http.
So it's kind of like an interface
between http and the etherium test.
HARPC chain clothes.
Okay,
we did that and now we can
ensure that web three a. Dot.
JS initialized by querying the accounts on
the blockchain. All right, we've, we've,
we've queried those accounts.
And lastly,
we're going to compile this
contract by reading it.
Hold on.
We're going to compile this
contract by reading it directly.
So I called it voting, got solidity,
converting it into a string.
Got It.
Then we'll say require
the solidity compiler
and then finally we can then compile
the contract and deploy it by saying
compile code equals solidity
dot compile code. Okay.
And so once I've done that, then I can
interact with the contract via that, uh,
no job via that node. Dot. Js Console,
or we could just interact with it
directly from our, um, html interface,
which I already have here.
So let's go ahead and interact
with it from our html interface.
So let's see.
I'll just say,
um, you know, Rama, again,
to see if it up increments and
it increments. Okay. So that is,
that is my simple voting app demo. All
the code for this is in the description.
Check it out on get hub. If you have any
comments, uh, please feel free to comment.
I love Saint Comments, uh,
for, for my videos. And, uh,
I hope you found this useful.
Hey, I hope you really liked
this video and if you did,
please hit that subscribe button for now.
I've got to go read,
decentralize the web.
So thanks for watching.